hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play cry fear
so now we will away to take care of this
big sumbitch I might have to kill him I
might have to kill him you know
I like him he's a nice guy nothing
nothing personal I just might have to
kill you you son of a [ __ ] so wow
you're tough ancient ah Hedgehog I've
killed you guys before and again you
were dressed like people from maybe I'm
not supposed to kill and I don't know
there we go
was that was that I didn't help at all
that's not well supposed to do can I
jump through here I can up [ __ ] it all I
didn't want to live anymore I couldn't
live with what I've done
oh so I don't need to kill him I just
need to jump better Oh
markiplier needs to jump better is that
what we need oh hey dear oh you're so
you're so tall ah I win you lose good
day sir
now as we venture off into the darkness
I can only imagine that there is a
chainsaw man waiting for me down here ah
are you are you blind fire up top F
you're not gonna make me kill myself
with that jeez
blam drop two shots straight to the head
that I can see don't question my
proneness my proneness levels are off
the charts still here that ghost behind
me
now this reminds me of a game I played
before constantly going back and forth
in these little rooms the vp70 ah
interesting I was I picked up a lot of
ammo for that so let me just do this
it's um a pretty powerful gun oh hello
you have a valve on your head what I'm
sorry I'm so sorry what I do ha ha
school go to hell and you die
holy bomb go to art what's this stop
screaming at me
music jeez oh man there's such a drastic
shift in the tone
I thought the oh my I don't have a
nebari oh oh oh oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] no oh
[ __ ] ah so rival God bechet's ah
very atmospheric don't you think oh I
know I can't see anything either but I'm
not leaving this gun not for a second
I'd wait hang on okay reload quickly
quickly quickly quickly quickly
seriously the guy whoever they hired or
got to make music for cry fear evil
genius oh oh you gotta be kidding me oh
you gotta be kidding me
I'm never gonna make this jump there's
no way that I am markiplier can make
this jump it is quite literally
impossible the fates will not allow me
to survive this jump I can't do it
ha hi there
there's literally no way that markiplier
that's me is going to survive this I
gotta kill this he's right in my way
and that music is just not letting up
damn it come on man
there we go jeez ah ha ha oh God
ha ha I thought I bit it for sure with
that that dodge forward I forgot if you
double tap killed odds in that direction
oh alright crazy about dick dial but
crazy ninja monkey dial there we go ha
ha done
ok his music time over now can we have
that end please I would love that to
stop ok utter silence is worse ok ok
that's good I like that
ok this is not good
I don't like this it's too quiet
is there something behind
question is is there something behind
you don't turn around
don't turn around he's right behind you
okay all right carry on just ignore him
he's fine he's just gonna stay there for
a bit
oh hello hey dirt switch em out that's a
lot of clock I'm assuming they're
gearing me up to fight hub oh hi hi
Simon
yeah looking good with that beard I'll
make you look older more like a war more
like a wha wha wha what why whatever is
this supposed to be my word crystals
hey this isn't supposed to be explained
by science supposed to be explained by
diabolical demon possession and insanity
stuff let me guess some crystal
infection yeah that's it that's the
stuff yeah by the way stop looking over
your shoulder it's making him angry okay
so
yeah here we go strange crystals aside
don't know yeah they're definitely
gearing me up for something and there's
got to be an interesting savegame name
for whatever the cave before door cave
before door that's not very descriptive
at all
all right let's reload placing two
bullets but can't be helped
reload reload all right so should I use
this now or later I'm thinking later
saving and the cave before the door
let's take this [ __ ] down whatever it
she here
embrace the darkness No thank you why
don't you shut up and show your face
yeah [ __ ] oh do you know where you are
I'm in a cave wait who are you your
question is who are you and what have
you done with your life I've murdered of
Hamilton I favor you remember come and
fight okay weirdo oh you're quick you're
quick job not quick enough dick oh
you're quick ha ha I'm not over there
are you done I'm not over there oh what
a silly Billy what a silly Billy okay I
don't know if he's gonna be like one
shot kill me damn where is there that
how does he go did I waste of oh Jesus
my guy was not supposed to be here
there's the shotgun oh you're so going
down oh I've got so many boys my name is
terrible but I have so many bullets you
don't even know man
you're getting yourself into why don't
you just give up right now oh what's
that I'm not over there oh so stupid
Wow get out get out of it oh yeah go
round the rock that's smart
at bacon - bacon
this guy isn't exactly the toughest boss
I've ever seen
I mean he's fast I'm feeling man but
other than that I don't how much just
say Oh dead and I've got so many why Hey
so you don't [ __ ] no you know God dick
Rock half those guys must be sneaking up
behind me trying to wait where do you go
where did he go where did he go where
did he go I don't see him hey buddy
buddy buddy
okay where'd you go buddy where'd you go
where'd you go buddy where'd he go oh
hey what are you doing hi
you can't hide from me why are you
thinking
you can't escape your fate man don't
even try
where'd you come on
go three more for you Wow one my mom
[ __ ] ah ah wait hey let me cheat back
this Ethel
ah but whoa how did I get here oh no oh
no oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no
oh no oh I thought that was it oh no ha
ha ha oh oh my ha ha ha not this not
this not this Oh God huh ah yes lie
bastards how is that now I finally
understand I've been wandering the whole
night wondering why I was being chased
by monsters uh-huh
but now that thing has reminded me
I remember committing suicide
I'm bet
oh and you know where I am now hell oh
okay I'm doomed to be endlessly running
scared forever you know you're doing
pretty good for being in hell this is my
torture my turtle punishment and there
is nothing in nobody
ah that's going to change I got ending
one of three nah how what happened what
did I do
how did that I have changed it I don't
even remember having a choice ha ha ha
ah oh okay visa credits amen that's a
really really really well made a custom
campaign I mean honestly that was one of
the best I've played that was incredible
that was right up there with the actual
campaign it was great I mean the maps
kind of was really together because
obviously was on the same cave texture
anakata got repetitive after a while but
either way it was still amazing the
atmosphere was right on par love the
music I love cry of fear if you don't
know already they're voting for the mod
of the year
you should definitely vote for cry fear
because it is by far my favorite all
right
I think it's a shoe-in to win the
half-life 1 category because people stop
making half-life one miles a long time
ago but still ah ah it's pairing a lot
of other game mods out there oh hello
what was that hi game ah ah I all right
fine fine kicking me out are you all
right oh man there's been a great game
love cry fear I might do more custom
campaigns as they come out there's two
here that I don't think I've done the
stairway scrolls of Shannon oh man I
think I've done all of these Hotel
tariffs done comedian klamath think
memories her isolation and recidivist I
don't think I've done the SDK campaign
but I all might try that later so thank
you all so much for watching click the
antics for more videos and I've done and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye
yo